t'aimes pas des gros atouts c'est un peu
comme t'as jamais goûté je crois c'est
un peu comme les fraises les français je
sais que tu aimes bien le week end
pendant une heure ou deux ce jeune père
de famille et sa petite fille se
retrouve dans ce potager fèves salades
carottes panais
il cultive sa parcelle depuis trois ans
un plaisir plus qu'une nécessité c'est
enfin essentiellement un loisir après
une réponse à la crise
oui parce que enfin si on voulait avoir
des légumes de cette qualité fait un
bios machin et tout ça nous coûterait
beaucoup plus cher je pense mais pour ce
jeune actif entretenir un jardin
nécessite aussi une véritable
organisation
on ne badine pas avec les fruits et
légumes surtout lorsqu'on a deux cents
mètres carrés à entre couilles et il ya
des moments où il ya des coups de bourre
comme un 10 ou au printemps en général
il faut lutter contre les mauvaises
herbes comme en ce moment et donc du
coup ça prend beaucoup de temps donc il
ya des moments où c'est un peu plus
difficiles que d'autres
mais bon on s'organise et on commence à
avoir de l'aide depuis quelques années
et malgré la liste d'attentes les
nouveaux jardiniers des parcelles
familiales rajeunissent la terre attire
les trentenaires pour le plaisir pour
leurs enfants pour la qualité de la
récolte ou faire des économies toutes
les raisons sont bonnes cette année il y
à de nouvelles quêtes comme cette
famille arrivée en février
ouais alors j'ai chaud aubergines
courgettes radis tomates fraises pour
ces novices c'était évidemment une
réponse à la crise mais il ya autre
chose à moi petit voilà j'ai un petit
jardin ça me manque énormément vivent en
appartement c1
on a le besoin d'un petit terrain pour
pouvoir respirer quelques heures de
calme et de simplicité dans un quotidien
souvent stressants l'occasion aussi
pourquoi pas de développer ses qualités
artistiques